all right we got some josh allen props
for the 2020 season a couple of them
come courtesy of draftkings first the
over
under for passing yards for josh allen
3300.5 very specific
draftkings i like it 3300.5 last year he
had 3089 this year he's got stefan diggs
you're going over you're going under i'm
going over i i think this is
i think we're gonna see a big leap for
josh allen in this offense up at buffalo
this year
you know offensive line they had some
young guys there last year they'll be
better but the big thing is like you
said
stefan diggs with john brown and cole
beasley
and second year tight end dawson knotts
knox who i liked and got another running
back up there
i think this offense is one of those
like we need to put the league on notice
to say watch out buffalo could be
dangerous on that side of the ball
but to echo your point i didn't see any
of those guys on the beach
they weren't playing in the sand they
weren't catching passes from josh allen
so hey yeah maybe get to work better be
time to find a way to get get these guys
to work if hashtag tommy's gonna do it
you know jared stidham's gonna be doing
it and you know other guys you're
competing with are gonna be doing it all
right over under
passing touchdowns for josh allen from
draftkings 21.5 last year he had 20
chris what do you got
i think they're gonna i think i'm going
over there too i think you know
there'll be more trust in josh allen
this year to where they're gonna
let him throw the ball inside the 10 and
inside the 20-yard line and the biggest
thing again with stefan diggs being
there
it just gives them a wide receiving core
that you go
wow they got a little bit of everything
and it's going to be tough to just say
oh they do this or do that with one guy
i mean all those guys are pretty
dangerous and uh
i'm yeah i'm expecting bigger numbers
than that
this last one is not a draftkings prop
but we're going to use it anyway over
under 500 rushing yards for josh allen
he had 631 as a rookie
he had 510 in 2019
now he played in fewer games as a rookie
he ran
more had more rushing yards and fewer
games his first year
down to 510 last year over or under 500
this year chris
i'm gonna go under i am i just think he
knows
what he's doing more with the football
he understands the defense more
so that'll lead him to throwing the ball
getting the ball out of his hands
and i think you're only going to see
mike to what you called it in the
playoff game last year i think you'll
see more running in big games from josh
allen
where they'll be getting you know game
plan design runs and then
in those big games you're playing better
defenses and he'll know at times hey i
got to extend this play i got to
scramble to make something happen and
all that so
uh yeah i expected to be under yeah i i
do too
i think that they are consciously having
him run less because they understand the
basic physics of it the more the guy
gets hit the more chance he's going to
get hurt
but if you use it you don't have to use
it all the time to make it a threat
if you use it just enough the defense
has it in their brain because when
they're watching the film as they
prepare
for the game they see the package of
runs
from the past month that josh allen has
has pulled off
that's right let's see what he can do so
you have to factor that in when you're
out there on the field and you're
thinking about what am i going to do
here do i need to stay back do i need to
go forward
how do i account for this do i try to
chase him too hard is he going to take
off around the edge
so you have the fear of the possibility
of him running
that maybe makes it easier to run your
pass offense i think that's that's
exactly it
i mean you're right you know first off i
want to off your first point you made
yeah the basic physics you can't
continue to play that style football
we took some plays out of that highlight
package of deja vu there
where he takes some big hits running the
football and you know we were our point
to show that was like
hey the guy's crazy you know he's
pedaled the metal
he really is he doesn't know how to
protect himself a little bit at times to
where you want to go man relax
so that's scary so they need to protect
them but your last point is very real
if you just do it once in a while where
hey it's read option oh josh allen just
ripped off 20 yards
you know that weak side linebacker he
doesn't need to see it
you know during the game for him to stay
honest there you're right he's going to
have watched it on film and go
man i know they keep giving the ball to
devin singletary here but
all those plays that i saw in my brain
during the week with josh
allen going down the sidelines i don't
want to be that guy that takes the bait
and goes after the running back and now
he's running down the edge for 50 yards
and
that's still very effective to do it
that way as well
so look even though there are some rough
spots that need to be ironed out in josh
allen's game chris and i are both
believers that the guy's got a high
degree of potential and now with tom
brady out of the division
somebody is going to become the best
quarterback in the division and there's
a chance that that somebody will indeed
be josh allen and there's a chance that
the best team in the division
will indeed be the buffalo bills you got
to kill the terminator though
before i'm going to sign off on that one
because the patriots are still in the
division until the
entire franchise is relocated to a new
division
you got to take down the top dog before
you can win that time
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports